[Music]
everyone this is Steve Weintraub with
Collider I'm here at the Kia Telluride
supper suite here at Sundance with
everyone behind Timmy failure mistakes
were made I want to first start by
saying congratulations on the movie I
thought it was fantastic
such a great family movie so I guess I'm
gonna start I'll start with you right at
the beginning and say I know it's a
little generic but some people will not
be familiar with the material talk maybe
a little bit about what the film is
about my best shot and then he will
correct me I was I was drawn to the
material because it is about this
nine-year-old boy 10 yeah I think all
right 10 9 then 10 or 9 10 year old
that's 10 or 11 guys I cannot argue it's
great I would know okay so 10 year old
boy who considers himself a world-famous
detective and uses this as a way of
dealing coping and connecting with the
world and of course like most general
detectives he has for his partner in his
agency a polar bear a 1500 pound polar
bear named total so it's you know that
old story yeah by the way why wouldn't
you yeah that's really the thing if you
could I wanted to jump over and say so
how how did this all connect yeah yeah
so somebody gave the book to Tom shortly
after it had come out and I guess Tom
read it and liked it so the two of us
met in New York City and got along and
then met again in LA and then I threw a
bit of a wrench into it by asking if I
could write on the movie with them and I
had never written a movie before so tom
was very generous and let me write and
that began a two-year partnership of
writing this whole movie so for me it
was a great education in film and
generous of Tom to let me do it with him
I thought the script was fantastic like
it made me laugh a lot I felt all the
characters are three-dimensional just so
well done talk a little bit about how
things changed from when you guys first
started outlining to maybe how what
ended up on
screener was always you know what I mean
yeah this one I will go first so I spent
about a year on the script and I was
really struggling with it and two things
occurred to me one that I had never
adapted a book before it took me a while
to realize that and to this book was
very very difficult to adapt because of
the type the structure of the book which
was incredibly sort of tangential in its
writing it's sort of sort of parallels
Timmy's brain which goes in a lot of
directions at once and it's really tough
to track one storyline or one narrative
so I realized after kind of breaking you
know hitting my head against a wall for
a while that I needed to kind of imposed
a little bit more of a structure and at
the same time trying to hold on to all
the wonderful things about the book and
including his voice most specifically
and that sort of randomness of his voice
so that was a tricky process I would say
yeah and I tried to not be too precious
about the book cuz I you know as Tom
explained to me early on a film is a
film on a book is a book so if there
were things that had to be changed we
changed him I mean the one thing I just
tried to keep his Timmy's voice like
just and but other than that if Tom
thought it was good for the film I
thought it was good for the film so of
course I'm very curious I believe I
could be wrong here this is your first
movie yeah got it because before this I
I just did it like a TV show and things
but really this was my first like big
film that I was like actually like a big
part of you know and I was so glad it
was just it was very odd experience when
I when I first found out that I got the
role um because I think I was I was
rocking was it yeah I know I was walking
home from the bus my dad kind of ran up
to me or something and he was like um so
you were casting TV fella and I was like
Wow I was I was kind of caught off guard
but then I was very just excited and
just so happy that I could be a part of
it especially after I met the cast and
in the Bears okay I've known him for
many years but the bear I I think it's
it's um it's good to acknowledge the
bear because he was actually a guy in a
nine-foot suit who was walking around
and his name is Michael and he just
became one of my really good friends
while we were shooting because you know
I was I'm with him most of the time and
yeah and I think it's it's good we
acknowledge him because he was sweating
in 90 degree weather in the Portland in
a giant polar bear suits so I wouldn't
have done it I mean I wouldn't have it's
actually important work right because it
gave this wonderful actor Michael from
that from Vancouver gave to me
Winslow's someone to really connect with
he was an actor and we knew that rich
McBride would do is amazing VFX work
afterwards which is pretty incredible
and but in the moment we really needed
someone there someone present someone
for as you said to become friends with
this is gonna be streaming on Disney
Plus talk a little bit about how it
ended up on Disney Plus and maybe like
behind the scenes was it ever and
originally conceived as trying to go
theatrical I mean I mean for me I think
Disney Plus is just such a great place
for it because so many people are gonna
see this movie
yeah it was initially when I started
when I initially talked to the people of
Disney about developing this and
creating it I've only you know made
movies so that was where my head was
and right when we got close to making it
they sort of they hesitated and it's
first time that's happened to me
professionally so I thought wow what's
going on and then I circled up with them
and they were like look here's the deal
the movies family movies in this range
we're gonna say for this new venture
we're having this about a year before
they announced
new place and we think this would be one
of the great film to kind of lead with
in some regard have it be one of our
first original releases and if you're
game and we kind of wrap my head around
it quite honestly excited I didn't know
you know we're all catching up to the
times and what this all means but more I
thought about exactly what you said the
type of movie it was why how it might
connect with audiences where they might
see it it made sense and I also realize
you know to Disney's credit it's a
really tricky movie to make right it
really kind of breaks a lot of molds in
a lot of ways it's not standard fare I
think the reason we're here at Sundance
with it is because I think it knows more
to independence and a mother and it does
sort of the classical structure of
Disney movies so I was thrilled that
they were taking a chance with this and
felt like it was a it was a not
necessarily a compromise but a perfect
middle ground and platform for the film
I actually heard that this was the first
Disney film to come to some there's I'm
pretty sure that's that's correct but
yeah decided to go this way because it's
been really fun so far and I've really
been here for like two days but it it's
it's already it's just it's such a cool
experience being able to be here and
that's one what's my first film festival
and it's it's my first Sundance two so
I'm just really glad I can be here I
think that one of the things that
audiences are really gonna love are you
have a lot of catch phrases and a lot of
certain sayings mistakes were made
exactly talk a little bit about where
did some of these catchphrases
originally you know come from and maybe
where there's some that you've thought
about adding to the movie I can see a
lot of kids in the near future saying
some of these things a lot of them come
from just the book some of them we sort
of found in the writing process one of
them that is said throughout which is
normal as for normal people was the
result of me yelling at my son one day
and saying Tom you got to be normal come
on help me out here and he said normal
is for normal people and that ended up
in the movie and as you see it's a
critical line so yeah personal
experience during the writing and from
the book now I want to meet your son
yeah
I'm always curious about the editing
process yeah because ultimately that's
where it all comes together yeah so how
did what were you surprised by when you
stepped in the editing room that it
worked maybe one you know there was
something there was a little bit of a
wire act with this film and balancing a
grounded kind of family drama with some
comedy and then sort of the more high
art of some of Timmy's flash away
fantasy sequences and finding the
balance and there and specifically his
performance and then that with the bear
sort of moving through this movie and
not acting like a typical Disney you
know animal it doesn't talk it doesn't
act in a heroic way it's just present so
all those pieces how they would fit
together but I will say I think we spent
so much time kind of refining the script
that it fit together pretty quickly
there wasn't a lot of major region we
went we did two days of reshoots on this
film which were really just because we
realized we could lean a little bit more
into some of the fantasy sequences that
we went down and reshot and also I think
that we could set up a little bit more a
signal to the audience of just what was
coming in the movie because we realized
that they hadn't really seen a movie
like this we started testing it and that
we were asking people like what does it
remind you of and no one had an answer
so we're like okay if that's the case
it's working the movies working but we
just want to figure out a way to plate
it a little bit in kind of act one and
set it up for our audiences and that's
that's where we put our kind of focus on
that but you know what editing was
really a lot of fun it was a fun movie
to make and a fun movie to edit I really
liked another thing I really like is the
way that it portrays real-life issues
and it's not shying away from real
problems and putting it through the lens
of Timmy's eyes and so you sort of talk
about that aspect that it's not you know
it's it's dealing with adult stuff yeah
well the bear is really sort of it in
the books is a stand-in for a father
who's not present and in the movie we
make that fairly obvious so as somebody
once said to me the the presence of the
bear is a measure of sort of the hole in
Timmy's heart so you see that very
clearly in some of the early scenes when
the way
be renters so yeah that's a serious
undertone that is in this movie we don't
hit it here but it's definitely under
here the whole time so it does have that
base rather serious base so that's true
something else you guys got to use
Portland for Portland you embrace the
the what Portland is yeah so talk a lot
about that aspect of the film and maybe
what you wanted to make sure got in
there from Portland well you know when
we when Steph wrote the book it was
really sort of set nowhere right right
right
and so we quickly realizes we're gonna
make a movie we couldn't shoot in
nowhere so we had to find a place and we
started thinking where could a boy have
a pet polar bear and store does still
fit in and that ledge is like basically
two cities or maybe three New York which
we didn't want to do New Orleans which
was too hot in Portland which fit the
bill and so we ended up in Portland and
I'd spent some time there Steph had
spent some time there I send Steph sort
of dispatched him there very quickly to
kind of like dig deeper on it and all
our research just felt like as soon as
we got there as writers forget about the
filmmaking aspect of it we just thought
the environment in the setting was right
the culture the people the inclusivity
the kind of the weirdness that makes
that town that town felt perfect for the
it was just a it was a super nice place
to shoot and and felt like this kid
would thrive there and also like you
know Tim being his mom don't have a lot
of money and we're trying to find a
neighborhood that they felt like they
would was socially economically right
for them and and you know as you
mentioned there's a lot of reality to
that what she can afford they have to
move because they can't afford their
place and you know she's working two
jobs here she's not around a lot for her
kid all those things that kids have to
deal with at some point the reality of
their parents and their struggles so we
leaned into that I also think it's
Portland was such a good place to do it
just because it's kind of a place where
people can just like be themselves and
they don't really have to fake anything
and I think that's kind of what I want
some people to just take off from this
movie is that you don't have to like
fake to be someone else just trying to
be confident in who you are and and then
you can honestly be a lot happier if
you're just being yourself instead of
someone that you aren't and then another
thing about when you said New Orleans
was too hot I think there's one day
where I was really curious so I looked
at the weather of New Orleans it was
like 103 degrees I was like yeah I'm
glad we didn't shoot there and it was
really hot yeah this global warming
thing isn't messing around no you are be
- you have Craig Robinson yeah Wallace
Shawn yeah Wallace Shawn is Wallace
Shawn I mean I love him talk a little
bit about you have a great supporting
cast so talk a little bit about some of
these people yeah I mean a lot of them
Kyle
also and feely lovely bond just like
some great actors and comedic actors
that really kind of rounded out the
ensemble and you know Craig's work I've
admired for so long and Wally working
with Wally was sort of a dream come true
for me
daryl is probably my favorite character
in all of the office so Craig is just
yeah Craig's a man
yeah and watching them them together was
really fun but all of them seeing seeing
Winslow have to kind of interact with
these three men in his life with Kyle
and and and Wally and Craig was just
very different the dynamic was very
different and very satisfying and not to
mention some of the other you know I
will say we shot in Portland and
Vancouver and Portland but in Portland
specifically the actors that we used
locally to fill out the cast were just
tremendous like you know sometimes you
get to tattoo you don't know you're
gonna find and everyone we including
Caitlin who played Flo who's just
terrific and scene-stealing and every
scene she's in so we were very very
lucky to end up there
she she was the one who played the
librarian yeah she's fantastic stand-up
comedian
shows yeah yeah I I normally don't like
to dive in on like sequels and all that
stuff but I can see this being a really
big hit if they if it ends up being a
really big hit is this something that
you've thought about like would we want
to do another yes yes we have we're
currently negotiating with sister
Phegley I know we have I think we would
all do it again in a minute you know at
the Steph's already started work on
another script and and I think there's
so much material in the books I mean
he's written how many people said oh
yeah there's so many great characters
and so many recurring characters so look
I think whenever you talk about a sequel
it's like do people want to come back
and spend time with the characters and I
think when I watch the movie now that's
one thing I really feel satisfied by
watching it is how many different
characters there are they're fun to
spend time with so that to me is a good
thing so I would not rule that out I was
gonna say one of the things that's great
is this is a complete story beginning
middle and end so it's you know it's but
it leaves room if you want it to
continue I wanted to just ask you with
the you have a number of things you
could pick from do you have the one that
you does the if you were to be say
making a sequel do you have the title do
you know which one it is yes I
understand yeah it's a combination I
mean the series is is seven books sure
so if I had my way the sequel is a bit
of a combination of two three and four
sort of put together truncated so yeah I
mean it's really for me it was a matter
of finding what new character that
wasn't in one would make this really
interesting so I think I found that
character from one of the books and so
yeah it's fun it's fun I like exploring
I mean for me I was saying to Tom with
the sequel part of the fun is we've seen
him interact with certain age
classifications and there was this one
that we hadn't seen what would he be
like around this type of person so the
character that I was focusing on for the
sequel is this character from one of the
books that it would be fun to just see
so I just kind of like to bounce him off
of you know different roles I'm just
wondering if that person would be in
high school
now that person would be old yes okay
yes yes got it for the three of you I
would imagine that making this was just
an awesome experience what's a day or
two that you will always remember from
the making of the film I think I'll
always remember the day where it was
this this scene where it's it's me and
Molly forked chloeís and there's this
one scene where the cat jumps up on me
and oh my god
and it was the cat was very difficult he
was just not cooperating that day and so
eventually it took so many scenes shots
and then eventually they just threw the
and then Khloe and gently no cat okay I
mean the highly-trained cat trainer
gently placed the cat on your lap that
were you mean Winnie I was doing all the
scenes with all the kids it was just so
fun because for most of the part I'm
with adults which was also very fun you
know working with Craig where I'm like
against the fighting things but I think
I will definitely remember most of this
because it's it's a big experience in my
life and it's a big step in my career so
I think that this is definitely
something that I'll remember I would say
is the writer the first page of the
first book is a car that drives into a
house and that that's a scene in this
movie and when you go on to the set and
you see 200 people around you literally
having built this home and a stunt
driver about to drive this car 40 miles
an hour into a house it's like what was
inside your brain is now in the real
world
and I just wandered around like how is
this even possible I mean something I
just typed on a page one day years ago
these people are all you know putting
this together that was a mind-blowing
sort of moment for me it's tough you
know there's so many moments so many
scenes it was sort of fun launching that
truck into the house kind of I just
never done a stunt that was cool but you
know all these different actors we got
to work with on this one it was truly
just in terms of shooting which isn't as
always as fun as the final product is it
was a very enjoyable experience I could
be mistaken but I think you have a film
coming out this Christmas talk a little
bit about what it's about and what
people can look forward to it's a little
bit different than Timmy it is about a
roughneck from Oklahoma played by Matt
Damon who travels to France to visit his
daughter who is serving time in prison
and the title is Stillwater I know that
Matt is very selective with his material
what was it like when he said yeah I'm
doing this was exciting he responded
very quickly to it and we started
talking about it and came together
pretty quickly and we again had a pretty
good time shooting it on that note I
will say congratulations
sincerely on this movie it's so good and
I hope you guys are able to make a
sequel because I would totally watch it
thank you